un or toutes les heures dans un accident
du travail le toit d'une usine
s'effondre à lille deux morts huit
blessés sud liban les affrontements
reprennent kurde valdan convoque le
conseil de sécurité après le coup d'état
en afghanistan un nouveau pion avancé
par l'union soviétique
jean françois kahn christian bilhac
nouveau ministre de l'éducation dialogue
avec les parents d'élèves
son portrait philippe harrouard
là messieurs bonsoir c'est un procès
exemplaire qui s'est ouvert aujourd'hui
aux assises des bouches-du-rhône
exemplaire parce qu'il s'agit de viol et
que le viol jusqu'à lors ce titre elle
se traitait de presque toujours en
correctionnelle et c'est ce qui est
arrivé il ya quatre ans lorsque deux
jeunes campeuse belges ont réclamé des
comptes à la société et comme nous
étions à un tournant des moeurs le
tribunal pour bien prouver qu'il y avait
crime et non pas simplement violence le
tribunal s'est alors déclaré incompétent
et a donc renvoyé l affaire en cour
d'assises
et pour bien manifester que la date
d'aujourd'hui est historique pour bien
montrer du doigt ce que ce forfait à
deux lâchers de traumatisant pour une
femme de très nombreuses personnalités
de bord très différents sont venus
aujourd'hui témoigner à aix en provence
un autre procès exemplaire celui là se
déroule aux états unis la mère d'une
petite fille torturée par quatre
adolescentes s'est retournée contre les
trois grandes chaînes de télévision
locales à qui il reproche d'avoir
favorisé ce genre de violence en
diffusant une série très suggestives
dans laquelle on retrouve très
précisément ce qu'ont fait ces jeunes
filles ce n'est plus un accident du
travail c'est une véritable catastrophe
deux morts huit blessés dont certains
gravement atteints c'est le bilan d'un
accident ce matin à lambersart dans la
banlieue de lille
le toit d'une usine s'est effondré sur
des ouvriers il a fallu plus de deux
heures aux secteurs pour dégager des
décombres les victimes de cet accident
une vingtaine d'employés se trouvait à
l'intérieur de l'atelier de fabrication
de cette entreprise de produits
alimentaires lorsqu'une dalle en béton
de 200 mètres carrés s'est abattue sur
eux dix ouvriers ont été bloqués par
l'effondrement des poutres métalliques
et des blocs de ciment
deux d'entre eux ont été tués problème
c'était de soulever ces matériaux pour
dégager la victime ça étant donné le
côté inaccessible aux véhicules de
levage on a dû procéder uniquement au
travail à la main la dalle à la main
avec des vers à bhl comme honda l'a
lâché point d'ancrage ont lâchés tous en
même temps et aucun problème de de
retenue tout doux tout est descendu
quant à savoir la cause c'est
impressionnant
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
ce sont les piliers supportant la
toiture qui aurait cédé l'atelier avait
été construit avant la dernière guerre
la dalle d'une épaisseur de 20
centimètres avait subi récemment un
examen d'étanchéité des spécialistes
n'avaient rien décelé d'anormal des
socialistes pourraient accompagner le
chef de l'état lors de son voyage à
l'onu le 26 mai c'est charles hernu qui
l'a dit tout à l'heure sur france inter
et qui prouvent ainsi que les
conversations sont très engagés
d'ailleurs valéry giscard d'estaing s'en
tient s'entretiendra pardon la semaine
prochaine avec les parlementaires de
quatre grandes formations de l'assemblée
de ses problème du désarmement
l'udf donc le rpr mais aussi le ps et le
pc gaston defferre se dit d'accord sur
le principe à la condition que le rôle
du député socialiste qui accompagnera le
prénom
vick ne soit pas simplement passif
triste lendemains de fête aujourd'hui à
paris le 1er mai a été marquée par des
violences dont nous vous avons parlé
hier soir et on a fait les comptes ce
matin 83 vitrines brisées quarante huit
interpellations huit gardes à vue deux
arrestations ferme sans compter un
certain nombre de véhicules endommagés
responsable ce que l'on appelle parfois
commandes commodément les autonomes ou
bien les incontrôlée je pense que nous
aurons l'occasion d'essayer de cerner
les motivations de ces jeunes gens que
l'on connaît mal et qui fait à leur
manière le dixième anniversaire de mai
68 le thème de nos dossiers de l'écran
tout de suite après le journal un 1er
mai marquée par par ailleurs par de
sérieuses failles dans le front syndical
cgt cfdt edmond maire ne défilait pas à
paris nous vous l'avons dit georges
séguy c'en était quelque peu offusqué et
le secrétaire général la cfdt viennent
leur expliquer qu'il valait mieux se
reposer un 1er mai que d'être absent au
grand rendez vous de l'histoire
edmond maire qui est surtout insisté sur
la nécessaire indépendance du mouvement
sa ligne cessé de dire que le change aux
politiques
c'est un préalable à toute amélioration
de la situation des travailleurs faut
combattre cette idée pernicieux l'action
syndicale peut obtenir des résultats il
faut partir au plus près de ce que
veulent les gens dans l'entreprise dans
le quartier saisir les revendications
bien voir où on peut les négocier où on
peut les régler les décider dans
l'entreprise
dans la branche au plan national est
réglée le plus possible de problèmes en
obtenant des résultats même partiels à
condition qu'ils aient bien un sens
positif pour les gens c'est d'ailleurs
au fond améliorer la situation des
travailleurs en redonnant confiance dans
l'action syndicale
je vais rencontrer demain le cnpn est ce
que cela veut dire que les négociations
pour l'essentiel se dérouleront d'état
major est un majeur
les négociations passe bien sûr par des
délégations qui sont confédéral le plus
souvent et nous le voulons surtout dans
les chambres patronales dont fédérations
syndicales et les patrons de chaque
branche mais cette négociation ne pourra
donner des résultats que si elle
s'appuie sur une mobilisation sur une
pression si les travailleurs dans les
entreprises semblent bien ce que veulent
obtenir des repas des responsables
syndicaux ce qu'il faut faire pour les
appuyer pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait
des résultats
sur quels résultats précis peuvent
déboucher ces négociations eh bien nous
voulons des minimes un professionnel
dans chaque branche nettement supérieure
au smic
réduire la durée du travail les 40 r la
cinquième équipe pour les travailleurs
postés la cinquième semaine de congés
payés la suppression du salaire aux roms
est un droit pour les travailleurs
d'intervenir de discuter de leurs
conditions de travail
voilà un encens ou pour arriver à des
résultats avant les vacances
edmond maire est revenu aussi sur la
lettre que lui a adressée raymond barre
et a regretté que le smic ne fasse pas
l'objet d'une concertation
la hausse du smic a été étudiée ce matin
par la commission supérieure des
conventions collectives on en connaîtra
le chiffre exact demain à l'issue du
conseil des ministres
social toujours le tribunal de commerce
de marseille a prononcé aujourd'hui la
liquidation des biens du groupe perrin
la des ensembles les plus importants de
réparation navale en france le groupe
emploie plus de 4000 personnes et on
sait vivre à peu près autant par le
biais d'une entreprise sous-traitante
les ouvriers occupent ou voiliers
l'entreprise depuis la semaine dernière
je vous dire que les chantiers navals
font partie des trois ou quatre grands
secteurs de l'économie française qui ne
marche pas bien en ce moment la période
des soins préventifs est terminée on en
est maintenant à la chirurgie
premier malade la sidérurgie le fleuron
de l'industrie lourde dame en guerre est
devenue un gouffre inquiétant la
compétitivité mauvaise la tonne d'acier
française et l'une des plus cher à
fabriquer d'europe
et puis la crise mondiale qui fait
fléchir la demande enfin les
importations à bas prix des pays tiers
malgré les récentes mesures
protectionnistes continuent à peser
lourd résultat des pertes gigantesques
cuisine aura perdu 2 milliards lourd
l'an dernier l'ensemble de la sidérurgie
française n'arrive même plus à payer les
intérêts de ces énormes têtes le plan
acier qui prévoyait l'an dernier une
restructuration d'ensemble un
assainissement financier d'ailleurs très
douloureux pour les créanciers les
contribuables et le licenciement de
16000 personnes
ce plan a scié donc ne sera peut être
même pas suffisant deuxième malade le
textile dans les synthétiques dans la
laine dans le coton comme chez boussac
par exemple les fermetures
d'établissements avec leur cortège de
licenciements sont si nombreux que la
gravité de la situation apparaît aux
yeux de tous les causes comme partout
importations en masse des pays à bas
salaires mais aussi mauvaise rentabilité
est surtout surcapacité c'est à dire on
fabrique trop par rapport aux besoins
réels
le tableau est toutefois un peu moins
dramatique que celui de la sidérurgie et
textile français a encore des atouts
notamment il exporte de plus en plus du
tiers de sa production et la rentabilité
peut elle aussi être améliorée surtout
s'il est tard et vise une réglementation
des prix des lancers de toutes parts
mais la surcapacité de production
demeurent et on voit mal comment la
réduire
sans réduire aussi l'emploi troisième
malade la construction navale secteur
plus petit que les deux précédents moins
de 30000 salariés mais il est lui menacé
dans sa totalité
on a trop construit des pétroliers
surtout que la crise de 73 à l'essai
dans leur parking les fjords de norvège
avant d'avoir servi les acheteurs se
font rares même les japonais qui voici
peut inonder le monde entier de leurs
navires sont pris à leur propre piège et
leurs chantiers navals licencie à tout
va en france aucune relance prévisible
avant quatre ou cinq ans c'est la
disparition certaine de nombreux
chantiers
seul espoir pour une forte proportion
des salariés le recyclage dans la
chaudronnerie lourde et le nucléaire
voilà parler de redéploiement industriel
c'est se pencher d'abord sur ces trois
dossiers sidérurgie construction navale
textile
ils représentent ensemble un demi
million de salariés et vouloir les
soutenir a défini mans avec l'argent du
contribuable à bout droit
ce serait pire qu'une erreur sans
transformation profonde ce serait une
faute
raymond burr l'adie clermont la semaine
dernière à l'assemblée la concurrence
intérieure et internationale doit être
désormais la loi fondamentale de notre
activité en d'autres termes l'ère des
subventions systématique est révolu
reste à savoir dans le cadre de cette
concurrence retrouver de combien
d'emplois les trois grands malades de
l'industrie française devront payer leur
survie la grève des employés de la ratp
va s'élargir demain par ici les
reconduites celle touche essentiellement
les bus mais pas le métro les jeunes
giscardiens sont ambitieux l'objectif de
leur mouvement qui s'appelle autrement
et de réunir 100 mille sympathisants
d'ici à l'élection présidentielle de
1981 nous écouterons leur porte parole
du 2 avril dans notre bien aimée journal
michel rocard attaqué sur tous les
fronts répond aux critiques aujourd'hui
à la suite de son passage au club de la
presse et de son jugement sur le pc la
qualité profonde du parti communiste est
finalement qu il ne sert à rien avait-il
dit sur radio monte carlo
michel rocard a essayé aujourd'hui de
dépassionner le débat en répondant tout
à la fois aux communistes
rené andrieu et au socialiste pierre
joxe madeleine renaud et jean louis
barrault ont reçu tout à l'heure à
l'elysée par le chef de l'état le
théâtre d'orsay a besoin de subventions
le présent la république s'est engagé à
faire tout son possible pour les aider
le chef de l'état qui par ailleurs se
rendra en corse début juin et en espagne
fin juillet cette dernière visite n'a
pas encore été annoncée officiellement
début des congrès des fédérations de
parents d'élèves
cela va commencer par la fédération
lagarde à royan à partir d'après-demain
interrogations des parents d'élèves
comme d'ailleurs des milliers
d'enseignants et des élèves eux mêmes la
personnalité du nouveau ministre après
trois ans vécus en compagnie de rené
haby les différents partenaires du monde
de l'éducation ont envie de savoir qui
est monsieur black nous aussi et c'est
la raison pour laquelle philippe
harrouard et philippe rayter donc suivi
pour nous
comment s'appelle le ministre de
l'éducation
monsieur hamid l'ancien ce qui
maintenant c'est la classe avec vous
venez de modulateurs je savais pas on
peut confondre christian belin qui est
en effet le 18e ministre de l'éducation
de la vème république
on le dit un homme de dialogue mais
aussi homme de commandement j'aime
commandes c'est vrai j'ai décidé j'aime
prendre un problème complexe et peu à
peu fait ressortir les éléments clés
pouvoir prendre une décision mais je
veux dire j'aime énormément convaincre
je ne sais pas comment des s'en convainc
depuis sa nomination
refurb la cnas effet de faire une
approche sur le terrain du monde de
l'éducation
une armée de 900 mille fonctionnaires et
de 11 millions d'élèves il ya une sorte
d'incompréhension entre l'ensemble la
société française et le monde des gens
chinian et le monde des enseignants en
est affectée il en souffre il a
l'impression d'être mal aimé je constate
à travers tous les contacts que j'ai une
très grande générosité dans le monde de
l'enseignement et je crois qu'à partir
du moment il ya cette générosité tout
est possible et je dois dire que cette
confiance nécessaire dans mon
enseignement
ce serait l'une des principales
préoccupations à quoi ça sert à ministre
de l'éducation pour une réforme au
niveau
l'enseignement depuis quelques années à
cause de l'évolution du monde on a été
amené à pas mal multiplié les réformes
et plus personne ne s'y retrouve bien ni
les enseignants je dois l'avouer ni les
élèves ni l'est pas il ya une loi qui
est votée cette loi il faut qu'elle soit
appliquée elle s'impose à tous
il faut que nous apportions peut-être
des aménagements au texte d'application
pour tenir compte des difficultés que
dans les faits nous constatons avec les
parents d'élèves et les enseignantes
numéro deux à la régie renault christian
bilhac a été un chef d'entreprise
remarque ministre du travail
un de ses fils au souci a été de trouver
un emploi aux jeunes et c'est à dire
qu'il sera surtout le ministre de
l'emploi des jeunes
son rôle serait alors singulièrement
restreint si sa vie bien sûr c'est en
particulier réussir sa vie
professionnelle et ce n'est pas que ça
qu'est ce que vous attendez vous du
ministre de l'éducation faire un
ensemble de courts qui sont moins
superficiel et qui attaquent plus la
préparation des études futures de
fonction il de mes fonctions importantes
ce sera de rapprocher à nouveau le monde
de l'éducation et la société française
est de redonner à l'enseignement au
monde de l'enseignement
la place prestigieuse qui a été la
sienne et devrait devenir la sienne
redonner raciale je dirai pas ce que la
première nouveau venu dans le monde
complexe de l'éducation monsieur black
commence donc à dessiner les grands
principes de son action il se donne
encore quelques jours avant de sceller
sa politique ses premiers contacts se
sont déroulées dans un climat détendu ce
qui ne s'était pas vu depuis longtemps
alors comme dirait un prof bon début
mais l'année scolaire est difficile un
chinois à paris mais ce cumul fui lé
vice premier ministre il est arrivé
aujourd'hui en france pour une visite de
dix jours c'est le dirigeant chinois
durant le plus élevé à venir à paris
puis la visite de teigne sur bing il y a
trois ans puis sites à caractère
essentiellement économiques la chine
désire en effet importé les techniques
de pointe utilisées par les industries
occidentales su plus accueillis par
raymond barre à son arrivée
la chine vous le savez s'est engagé dans
la modernisation de son économie si l'on
les quatre modernisations à la
modération d'économie et l'agriculture
sont apparaissent comme deux
préoccupations pour ce pays
nous sommes en mesure de lui apporter
une aide et c'est ce que nous allons
étudier ensemble et puis toujours à
pékin cette déclaration du chef
d'état-major britannique déclarations
jugées quelque peu intempestives ou en
tout cas maladroite
nous avons tous deux à notre porte un
ennemi dont la capitale et moscou a dit
sans ambages en île cameron argentine le
président du parti radical arrêté hier
soir en compagnie de plusieurs ses amis
ricardo balbine à 74 au liban maintenant
la situation devient franchement
malsaine au moment même où se réunissent
à new york les membres du conseil de
sécurité les palestiniens s'entraînent
très nettement aux casques bleus ils ont
bombardé tout à l'heure une caserne des
forces de l'onu on dit même qu'il y
aurait des blessés parmi les français
d'autres accrochages ont opposé la nuit
dernière palestiniens et casques bleus
français
alors pour mieux comprendre la situation
et les positions des uns et les autres
vont suivre avec notre offre spéciale en
régaler la difficile mission des casques
bleus français
carte la position stratégique des uns et
les autres au liban aujourd'hui tout le
monde contrôle tout nu dans ce pays on
ne compte pas moins de douze fraction
armée différents la plus importante
restant l'infraction palestinienne de
dix à vingt mille hommes cette présence
palestinienne a été légalisé par les
accords du caire de 60 non signataires
les états arabes l'état libanais et l'ol
paie la base de cet accord était de
faire cohabiter l'état libanais et
l'insurrection palestinienne mais au
moins sur trois points le pouvoir
libanais s'est retrouvé grand perdant en
effet les accords du caire n'avait pas
pour finalité de permettre aux
palestiniens d'une part d'occuper le sud
liban
d'autre part de l'essai face à face
l'état libanais et israël
en un mot le pot de terre contre le pot
de fer enfin d'aboutir à la destruction
de l'autorité libanaise à l'époque de la
signature de ces accords le président de
la république en exercice et est charlie
l'accord du caire a été un accord de
cessez le feu
un modus vivendi établi entre l'autorité
militaire libanaise et le commandement
militaire palestinien pour mettre fin à
des affrontements armés qui avaient lieu
entre l'armée libanaise et des milliers
de combattants palestiniens qui
s'étaient infiltrés les olives on avait
un vestige dû au fait que l'action des
commandos palestiniens en octobre 1969
était la seule action à l'ab après la
défaite des armées régulières arabes en
1967 aucune disposition de l'accord du
caire pour permettre à au commandement
palestiniens et leur troupe
palestinienne d'occuper la moitié du
territoire libanais en 1975 avant la
guerre civile
l'armée libanaise comptait 18 millions
douze mois ces militaires sont restés
consignés dans leurs casernes
le pouvoir politique en place partagée
entre chrétiens et musulmans pro
palestiniens ne se décidant pas à les
faire intervenir cet attentisme a eu de
conséquence la création des milices et
l'éclatement de l'armée en fractions
confessionnelles la restauration de
l'autorité libanaise passe donc
aujourd'hui par la création d'une
nouvelle armée composée en majeure
partie donne nouveau pluviers à 21 ans
alors et sans fatigue et de des
événements alors ils sont venus dans
l'armée pour sauver le liban et pour
défendre la la terre qui est toujours
menacée j'espère qu'il va accomplir
cette fois tous ces jeunes se sont
engagés pour cinq ans il compose la
première brigade forte de 600 heures à
90% ce sont deux nouvelles recrues et
pour éviter tout problème d'ordre
politique ou religieux le commandement a
décidé d'installer ces jeunes militaires
à l'écart sous des tentes
le plus loin possible des casernes où
l'on trouve encore des fraction
dissidente de l'ancienne armée du libre
c'est une armée de métier tous ces gens
sont des volontaires
en ce qui concerne les les promotions il
ya un comité spécial pour le recrutement
qui travaillent dans ce domaine avec
certainement la brh intéressé au
deuxième d'euros militaire il faut déjà
arriver chez nous ils sont tout à fait
impartial et à te feras ton de cette
nouvelle armée cela revient à poser le
problème de la présence palestinienne
armée au sud-liban donc des accords du
caire les palestiniens n'ont rien à
gagner dans une révision de ces accords
les états arabes non plus alors aux
libanais de se débrouiller sur place
avec cette présence jugée ici de plus en
plus encombrante proche orient par
ailleurs il y a une curieuse
redistribution des cartes
anouar el-sadate comme jimmy carter ont
tenu des propos un peu déconcertant le
président égyptien 13 de véritables
couronne à jimmy carter tout en semblant
se rapprocher du front du refus et dur
du monde arabe
et pendant ce temps le président carter
lui à plomb
dès demain menahem begin bref on a un
peu de mal à suivre
c'est en termes très chaleureux que le
président sadate qui prononçait un
discours un sombre al-khaimah a parlé du
président carter en disant de lui qu'il
joue aujourd'hui un rôle historique en
faveur de la paix au moyen-orient
l'attitude américaine mérite notre
estime que président sadate qui rappelle
que le carter reste attaché à la
résolution du conseil de sécurité qui
stipule le retrait des forces with rel
et l'israélienne de tous les fronts qui
monsieur st et cela peu de temps après
que monsieur carter a en réalité affirmé
que l'évacuation de tous les territoires
occupés n'était pas indispensable non
plus que l'établissement d'un état
palestinien indépendant et monsieur
carter devait aller bien au delà dans la
gamme des propos agréable à entendre
dean en recevant en même temps que 500
rabbin et personnalités religieuses
juives invités à une vaste garden party
à l'occasion du 30e anniversaire l'état
d'israël je carter a réaffirmé ce qu'il
appelait l'engagement total et absolu
des états unis envers la sécurité
d'israël et promis que son pays
resterait aux côtés d' état juif non pas
seulement pendant encore 30 ans mais
pour tous où on comprend le ravissement
de le feu légumes qui a dit c'est l'une
des plus grandes déclarations morale
jamais entendu et je dois vous rappeler
que notre magazine question de temps
commémorera demain le 30e anniversaire
de la naissance d'israël avec
d'étonnantes archives de 1947 sur
l'exode des juifs d'europe vers la
palestine et avec une interview du
premier ministre mène béguines par polna
animations là sourit jean-pierre
elkabbach à l'organiste en premier pays
à reconnaître le gouvernement issu du
coup d'état l'urss c'est facile à
comprendre le régime est dirigé par
l'ancien responsable d'un parti commises
prosoviétique clandestins et c'est jean
françois kahn un pion de plus sur
l'échiquier soviétique dans le monde
apparemment en effet
on pourrait penser qu'un coup d'état
militaire même procommuniste en
afghanistan ce petit pays de structures
d'ailleurs tout à fait féodal qui
établit très très beau mais ce retour
tout à fait féodal bon on pourrait
penser que c'est quand même un événement
secondaire mais effectivement quand on
place ça dans un contexte de jeu alors
là on fait une constatation tout à fait
surprenante
rappelez-vous en 1975 les derniers
américains quitté le vietnam il ya trois
ans bien depuis le vietnam est devenu
communiste
le cambodge a choisi un autre communiste
différents mais enfin il est devenu
aussi communiste le laos s'est donné un
régime de type communiste ensuite il ya
eu le processus de la décolonisation
portugaise qui a permis au mozambique à
la guinée-bissau puis à l'angola après
une guerre civile très très difficile
très âpre de se doter également de
régime qui se réclament du marcisz et
même du marxiste léniniste
puis coup d'état en ethiopie et après
une période confuse on a vu surgir à un
groupe de militaires qui eux aussi se
réclament du marxiste léniniste et qui
ont même réussi à triompher d'une guerre
non déclarée avec la somalie et enfin
l'afghanistan coup d'état et vous l'avez
dit on voit apparaître un responsable
d'un parti communiste clandestin et
alors là on croise en compte et ça fait
8 ça fait 8 et si on ajoute madagascar
l'ancien dahomey qu'on appelle le bénin
et même les seychelles qui se sont
également dotés de régimes socialistes
radicaux ça fait même onze pays alors
c'est assez surprenant parce que il y a
quinze ans il ya vingt ans les
américains seraient intervenus comme ils
l'ont fait en corée wire militairement
pour beaucoup moins que ça alors il faut
en déduire qu'il ya un changement
d'optique de la politique américaine et
qu'aujourd'hui peut-être les américains
considèrent que le véritable enjeu est
ouest se joue sur le plan technologique
et économique et non pas en angola et en
ethiopie voilà jean françois kahn qui
vient d'écrire un livre qui n'a pas
beaucoup de rapport avec l'afghanistan
mais qui se lit d'une traite on prend
les mêmes et on recommence il s'agit de
la campagne électorale en france et ce
n'est pas disons un livre très tendre
les suites de la catastrophe de l'amoco
cadiz la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale a d'ores et déjà élu son
président le centriste andré colin
rapporteur
le giscardien jean marie giraud
l'assemblée va également créer une
commission denquête un attentat à
l'explosif cette nuit à lorient contre
la shell france aucun blessé mais les
dégâts sont importants
c'est le deuxième attentat contre des
bâtiments de la chaîne en bretagne il
est difficile de ne pas voir de rapport
avec la marée noire
encore des initiatives généreuses aux
propos des sinistrés au profit des
sinistrés pardon ainsi l'équipe de
football de morlaix qui organise
apprennent un grand match entre l'union
des artistes avec adamo brasseur et
compagnie entre les vétérans du stade
borgésien je dis donc 17 heures à
morieux voilà qui nous amène tout
doucement à la grosse actualité de la
soirée c'est à dire la dernière journée
du championnat de france de football
soir être très indécise puisque monaco
comme nantes peuvent être champion de
france
monaco qui reçoit ce soir bastia et qui
ne va pas être à la fête
si j'en crois ces images du match de
dimanche bastia saint-etienne bastia qui
a imposé sa loi dimanche soir à
saint-etienne avec des buts de cases de
zerby crime aux airelles et ce soir
l'arbitré du duel monaco nantes pour
l'attribution du titre de champion de
france 1978
face à monaco les bastiais veulent en
effet effacer les traces d'une défaite
sur leur terrain au match aller et dans
l'euphorie de la coupe de l'uefa et de
la victoire fracassante contre
saint-etienne ils sont capables de tous
les exploits
ce serait alors à condition que nantes
l'emportent sur nice en beurre au même
moment la conclusion malheureuse pour
monaco d'une brillante saison du côté
nantais les choses ne paraissent pas non
plus très faciles ni c'est peut-être une
équipe sur le déclin mais elle reste
quand même une formation capable du
meilleur
en résumé ce soir monaco est champion de
france s'il gagne et quel que soit le
résultat nantes
il est encore champion s'il fait match
nul et que nord ne va pas nice par plus
de trois buts d'écart mais il n'est que
vice champion s'il est battu et que l'on
gagne
à noter que dans le bas du classement
lens reims ennemis millions permettront
de savoir qui de lancer de nîmes
accompagnera 3 et pointent en deuxième
division
j'ai appris il ya une heure le décès du
compositeur soviétique 4 chaque organe
c'est l'auteur de la fameuse danse du
sabre il avait 75 voile avant de
refermer ce journal un petit peu
d'autosatisfaction
il s'agit de l'hommage rendu ce week end
par télé poche à mon adorable consoeur
martine allain regnaut consacré en même
temps que de nombreux professionnels de
la radio et de la télévision
ça se passait à hammamet en tunisie et
martin a reçu des mains de mme del duca
un kangourou d'or elle n'était pas vous
allez le voir par la seule pour un tel
but puisque bernard pivot pour
apostrophe alain jérôme que nous voyons
l'instant pour les dossiers de l'écran
et puis maurice faille vis pour 10 788
ont également été récompensés voilà le
temps demain sera assez morose une zone
de nuages et de pluie sur l'ouest le
matd atteindra les régions de l'est le
soir après son passage et bien le temps
sera variable sur l'ensemble du pays
c'est hervé claude qui vous présentera
la dernière édition du journal vers
23h30 donc après les dossiers de l'écran
vous remercie de nous avoir suivis en
vous souhaitant une très bonne soirée à
demain